[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look of course at
what's on the front pages time then to
see what's making the headlines with kev
mcguire associate editor of the daily
mirror and ali mirage columnist at the
article welcome to both of you
so let's see the front pages then shall
we the guardian leading with a stark
warning from the former prime minister
gordon brown who urged the pm to take
control of energy firms that will not
cut bills
the ft says the easing in u.s inflation
spurs hope that the pace of price rises
has peaked
the metro leads with energy bill hell
and calls the crisis as bad as covid
well knight of the living dread this is
martin lewis calling on politicians to
do something about the energy crisis and
that's in the daily star while the front
of the eye has energy firms behind the
price rises are being threatened with a
new windfall tax
daily express focusing on the supply
chain crisis which leaves pharmacists
struggling to provide vital
medicine and the daily telegraph focuses
on the unprecedented weather in the uk
saying we are at exceptional risk of
wildfires as temperatures continue to
rise and the daily mail sheds light on a
new report that finds victims of
burglary are being let down by the
police while the delhi mirror quotes
kate greville
giggs's ex-girlfriend who told the court
she felt like a slave
well reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
listen to our guests so let's go to them
shall we and bring in kevin mcguire from
the mirror and ali mirage from the
article welcome to both of you um we
didn't show much those newspapers but
now we will i promise um something wrong
with our kit and caboodle but anyway um
ali let's let's go to the eye energy
firms threatened with a new windfall tax
um you know this meeting at number 11
downing street on thursday is that um to
be seen to be doing something or is it
actually doing something
well it's partly to be seen because no
material decisions are going to be made
until a new prime minister is in place
which is going to take another four
weeks or so and this comes on the back
of gordon brown the former uh labour
prime minister calling for the
government to really take action quickly
and also martin lewis the uh the actual
um consumer champion also talking about
that uh and gordon brown was saying that
there should be a cobra meeting to
actually look at this uh and the
government takes you take action now it
shouldn't wait for weeks on end to do
that this is partly a response to that
quasi quarter and the deemed the harvey
the chancellor and the business
secretary respectively are going to be
getting together to put pressure on the
energy firms at the moment energy
companies are already facing a
corporation tax
of
30 percent they play a supplemental tax
of 10
and on top of that
there's a winful tax already been
imposed of 25 so they are paying a lot
in tax already however there's been a
lot of scrutiny particularly around bp
uh and others who are making massive
profits eight billion plus
in q2 this year some of that money is
being returned to shareholders uh in the
form of share buybacks and dividends and
things like this
so there is a lot of pressure but
there's also the question about well if
you want to go down gordon brown's road
of trying to nationalize these companies
uh that's all very well uh but that is
gonna impose a further burden on the
government so that's where we are yes i
mean you quoted the guardian there take
control of energy firms that will not
cut bills brown tells the prime minister
he's been very vocal some might say the
labour party's been quite quiet but um
energy companies that cannot offer to
lower their bills should be temporarily
brought into public ownership there is a
difference is they're not between energy
providers and the oil giants in some
cases kevin and companies like british
gas for example the consumer part of
their business is actually losing money
because they've taken on a lot of the
customers of the of the failed companies
and they're having to provide actually
their electricity and gas at a loss now
so you know there's a divide here you
can't lump everybody together at this
point
no you're quite right except they're all
making money uh producers and suppliers
because suppliers are passing on the
extra prices they're being charged
which are
largely as a result of putin's
unprovoked invasion of ukraine hold on a
second just so just quickly if the
energy providers are having to get the
energy from the market the wholesale
prices are going rampant as you know and
they are capped what they can charge i
know it's changing every three months
they are passing it on which is why
prices are going up and an an average
typical household was paying at the
beginning of april this year 1 200
pounds a year and could be paying 4 400
pounds
a year by the beginning of next year i
mean it's an incredible change over nine
months it's more than a trouble so those
suppliers are passing on those that
doesn't mean they're making the extra
profits that's all the point i was
making do carry on yeah yeah but you but
you saw british gas as profit rocketed
at one point uh was it 1.3 billion it
was was it three times it went up and it
wasn't on the scale of bp and shell but
british gas itself is hugely profitable
you can you can act in two different
ways on this one is you can put all the
burden on the individual or you
collectively decide we as a society will
cover that cover that cost and two you
can allow those price increases to go
ahead which are inflationary or you can
stop him in which case you need to then
subsidize the energy companies now of
course we spent rather a lot earlier in
the year when some of those suppliers
that have been offering cheap deals
began to go bust and wanted the
customers to be taken over by by other
other companies and this is where the
gordon brown piece in the in the
guardian is he's saying look cancel the
constantly increase that's planned in
october and david the leader of the
liberal democrats argued this earlier on
and then you will somehow have to either
subsidize those suppliers or if they
can't still commercially cope you then
take them into temporary public
ownership which is what happened with
the banks or some of the banks are rbs
in particular during the global
financial collapse in in 2008 so gordon
brown's got a track record on
intervening in this way but it is the
question is how much of those increases
which are absolutely huge do you allow
to go on the consumers who if you've got
if you've got the median wage of 31 000
pounds a year that's before tax and
national insurance you're paying four
thousand pounds four thousand two
hundred four thousand four hundred
pounds a year you will be absolutely
crippled and gordon brown earlier in the
week had all those figures showing half
the country will be in what's called
fuel poverty because that it's spending
more than 10 percent of their income
just on their fuel bus so there are huge
political and economic and financial
choices to be made
here
and we started off with the i
which has nadim zawari the temporary
standing chancellor no one really
expects him to be there whether it's
rishi sunak or liz trust who is going to
be the next prime minister he's saying
well perhaps there might be another
windfall tax if energy companies don't
invest more
in renewable energy well that's a long
way off that's an excuse not to increase
the
the windfall tax broker yep a lot of
money is it five five billion or so
raised by that winful tax it's not
matched the increase in the producers
profits which you've just soared and
they haven't done that because of any
extra investment it's because of
disruption and shortages in world
supplies just means they can charge a
lot more for what they've been producing
for for some time
i'm afraid
well yeah the market is not working in
the interest of consumers at the moment
if you're getting huge amounts going to
shareholders and consumers are having to
foot that bill this is what the whole
political economic and financial
argument is
there is war in europe and many of those
shareholders are all our pension funds
so that's the they say you do need to
bear that matter
let me get to ali on this let me get let
me get early on this now this idea of
temporary public ownership
the gordon brown idea you know that's a
stage too far certainly for this
conservative leadership liz trusts again
today rejecting the idea of any further
wimpful taxes suggesting it sends out
the wrong message
and that it inhibits investment the
problem is if if you set a level that is
beyond what you anticipated your
earnings to be
then that does not necessarily change
your investment plans does it ali do you
think we will see another one
well look uh liz trust has been very
clear that she doesn't believe a further
when full taxes to wage go in fact uh
there was talk uh of her
rescinding this original windfall tax
itself reversing it i don't know exactly
what her policy is on that right now
given the pressure that any new prime
minister is going to be under but what
is clear is that only 24 hours ago uh
list request was saying that handouts is
not the way forward she wants to give
people back more of their own money to
make their own decisions and is now
trying to keep the door open to that and
it's not going to be drawn on what is
going to be or not be included in an
emergency budget because she knows and
anyone knows that the
position that people are going to be
facing it's absolutely dire i mean
kevin's outlined it it's stark
energy bills are trembling martin lewis
the
founder of money-saving expert the
consumer champion is saying that this is
of a scale now
akin to the early days of the pandemic
where bodies were piling high in
european hospitals and we were
slow to act to sleep at the wheel
allowing people to attend large sporting
events you remember that cheltenham uh
racing festival that took place which
was a super spreader event so that's
what he's saying this is dire and the
price cap is going to be reviewed at the
end of august
it's then going to be kicking in uh in
october people can't wait that long
decisions have to be made now that is
the key thing i mean rishi sunak has
been quite clear that he will
give more help he hasn't been he hasn't
been transparent about exactly how much
more you remember back in may that 15
billion that was announced including 400
pounds for every household which by the
way i personally if i was chancellor not
that i ever would be uh given that honor
but if i was i wouldn't have channel and
channeled that to everyone i would have
channeled it to the poorest in society
um along with the 650 pounds it was
given to people on on benefits and other
support as well so it is a dire position
and just bear in mind
how
how delicate the fiscal position is that
we face we've spent 400 billion on covid
we've got 2 trillion of public debt
we've got rising interest rates and
we've got inflation heading towards
according to the bank in governor 13.4
this is a really really difficult
position the worst since the 1970s it
requires competent level-headed grown-up
government and look if you took public
utilities of this nature need to be
temporarily nationalized i'm i'm a free
marketer i'm not in favor of
metallization generally however there
are dire times which call for extreme
measures and we may get to that point
but let's see first uh what the energy
companies can do further to try and
alleviate some of the pain here yeah
kevin i want to move on i know i know
you're watching to come back do you mind
if i move on to the blue armor
no not at all i was just watching sky
earlier and you outlined how price
increases have been larger in the uk and
government interventions lower and the
two are linked than in france germany
italy and spain
yeah okay
yeah yep
we'll see if we can run that again later
this uh so everyone can see it too
um but in the meantime let's get to the
deli telegraph which is blue on blue
attacks once again and this is uh two uh
cabinet members who said that rishi
sunak resisted attempts to cut brexit
red tape on two issues
one
which makes it harder for pension funds
to invest in uk infrastructure and
secondly this northern ireland protocol
bill which is aimed at unilaterally
changing the terms of trade in the
province um you know many people have
been very critical of that um but this
uh shows once again they said that um
he'd slowed attempts to ditch uh
elements that showed that they could
break free from brexit so what do you
think about this blue on blue and
specifically these allegations against
mr sunak
oh yeah the winners are the all the
opposition parties uh labor lib dems smp
greens play comic whoever you like
because the tory party is turning
tearing itself apart in
in in public and what is said can't be
unsaid and it will be on the record and
it will be used but this is simon clark
the chief secretary of the treasury
quasi-quality the business secretary
both supporters of liz trust both back
brexit at the time in 2016 as did
rishi sunak but liz trust didn't and
they know it's a soft uh
front of hers where she can be attacked
because she now has the zeal of this con
of the convert but it's disputed by
rishi soon act certainly on the question
of the northern ireland protocol at the
time he was right to uh to be wary that
you could spark a trade war given that
that brexit has been not a disaster for
for trade as a any responsible
chancellor you would you would see that
was a weak uh a weak point you've got to
go uh cautiously never mind just
following in the national law and
keeping the treaties that you sign and
not jeopardizing peace in northern
ireland but no it's it's the
conservative party just uh just kicking
itself biting lumps and gouging eyes
it's absolutely incredible i mean in
some ways it's wonderful to watch but
i'm not sure it's good for the
conservative party okay lots more still
to come including uh the weather we are
all experiencing the daily telegraph is
focusing on the unprecedented weather um
an exceptional risk of wildfires back
with that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now kevin mcguire
associate editor of the daily mirror and
ali mirage columnist at the article
welcome back to both of you um so um
kevin let's take a look at the daily
telegraph exceptional risk of wildfires
one spark enough to cause destruction as
an unprecedented warning is made across
most of southern england and this is a
warning to people on sunny days you know
be careful what you set light to isn't
it
no absolutely the the met office uh it's
fire severity index now exceptional risk
and that map that graphic on the front
of the telegraph that uh that red area
is this exceptional area stretching down
from nottingham to sussex
according to the uh the telegraph and it
shows you the uh the seriousness of this
problem uh we've been so little rain
we're in a drought the host pipe bands
are
gradually coming in in parts of the
country not all parts of the country in
scotland north east for instance
not not affected with the parts too but
there's a large swathe of the country
now where it's not only that shortage of
water and restrictions on how we use it
it is the fact that there's a threat to
life and property and we we saw in the
first uh heatwave when the record
temperatures over 40 degrees the
terrible fires around london in
particular and what happened to those
houses in the east of london people
losing their homes and their belongings
i think it's you know there's a warning
here we've all we've all got to take um
precautions we've all got to be careful
and people using barbecues in particular
or smokers thrown in right away um
cigarettes you could really start an
inferno and we're living now in large
parts of the country in a tinderbox
britain yeah national farmers union
can't water crops they say grassroots
sport also threatened with chaos as the
heatwave has rendered many rugby
football and cricket pitches too
dangerous to use that's how the
television describes it it's having a
big impact isn't it on large parts of
southern britain uh in the meantime ali
let's go to the financial times there is
donald trump fist raised um taking the
fifth he says in uh this civil probe
into his business dealings tell us more
i mean this is uh this is basically um a
probit at his house at mar-a-lago resort
uh which happened uh yesterday uh the
fbi uh investigated because the national
archives were uh convinced that certain
documents had been taken to his
mar-a-lago house
which he describes as his beautiful home
and was intercepted by the fbi now this
is really now playing to
donald trump's base we know that he's
potentially mulling a bid uh for his
third attempt at the presidency in 2024
this is going to galvanize the base he's
already
had all the issues around the january 6
capital
riots uh but donald trump's going
nowhere and this again is a he's now
gonna call into question
the independence and the politicization
of the judiciary in the u.s in what is
already a very very divided some would
say hatefully divided country uh which
shows no signs of uh quelling those uh
divisions within it and the republicans
by the way are still now in this
quandary of whether to continue a donald
trump or to cut ties with him